voilà maintenant une page de détente une
plage de détente même après cette série
de télégrammes gris et noir vous allez
assister à la naissance peut être d'un
nouvel art il y avait déjà un instrument
de musique assez torturé le synthétiseur
à micro ordinateur il y avait aussi des
spectacles son et lumière grâce au laser
et bien georges leclercq à proposer à
des artistes du 10 10 et un même
ordinateur pour piloter la musique et le
liseur
le résultat vous allez voir est assez
étonnant
oui regardez ses formes géométriques
elles sont dessinées par un laser elles
suivent le rythme de la musique dans
leur forme et dans leur mouvement
en fait le synthétiseur de musique et le
laser obéissent un même cerveau un
micro-ordinateur maniées par des
artistes qui viennent d'inventer devant
vous un nouvel instrument
chaque mouvement de ces petits miroirs
est en quelque sorte une note
l'effet lumineux peut être puissant ou
obscurs la lumière concentré où est allé
le balayage lents ou rapides et cela en
fonction de la musique derrière ces
instruments des hommes s'activent ils
sont électronicien informaticiens
bricoleur mais aussi compositeur artiste
musicien le côté lumière c'est l'équipe
de laser graphics elle assure entre
autres la comédie musicale moïse qui
passe en ce moment à paris avec elle en
invité michel gay ce compositeur et
inventeur de synthétiseurs ensemble ils
ont créé ce spectacle inédit uniquement
pour vous
est ce là un nouvel art qui est en train
d'être peut-être à condition que son
usage ne soit pas réservée aux boîtes de
nuit à condition que ces jeunes puissent
continuer à s'exprimer à construire leur
appareil à pouvoir montrer leurs oeuvres
ils sont un exemple artistique de ceux
qui ont compris ce que l'on pouvait
réaliser avec un micro ordinateur plutôt
que d'en avoir peur il faut le maîtriser
par exemple en pratiquant le concours
micro lancé par la mission informatique
et antennes
et ce à l'aide d'un petit appareillage
qui se trouve à côté de moi et que l'on
peut modifier à volonté ou le voyez il
suffit de bouger avec les mains et on
arrive à des choses tout à fait
étonnante donc les heures système
georges leclercq coupe de france